sucker yeah a little closer little
closer all right don't worry fellas dick
how you doing very nice to meet you nice
to meet you too you're remarkably normal
oh thanks I know people are we struck at
how normal I am am i it's like wow
really I think my main issue the maze I
guess seeing a famous child and yeah
yeah that's a very unusual maze yeah my
life is unique to me that's what I like
to say you know yeah and I'm almost like
a peerless person like to a certain
extent there's not too many people I can
look left and right and we you know I
I'm like we have similar experiences
yeah is there anybody that you ever
contacted like Jodie Foster or someone
who's made it through and seems pretty
put together not really no no not really
I mean it's kind of a weird cold call
you know hey Jodie Foster such a small
clan of people like if a comic called me
that I knew you know they wanted to talk
to me I would talk to them because it's
such a small club gonna people I mean we
do have our weekly therapy sessions yeah
Elijah Wood Jodie Foster you know yeah
like we all get together and yeah we we
weep you know it's actually do primal
screaming that's what we do I was
describing what it was like I have a
friend who Ricky Schroder who is you
know obviously he was very famous for
news young as well and my favorite theme
songs TV theme songs and I was saying
like the way you developed is not like
the way the recipe calls mm-hmm like the
recipe calls for you to have a childhood
and try to figure out life and then
become a man and try to find yourself
and then try to find your path and by
the time you be he became a man he was
already famous and the same thing with
you you were already famous as you were
developing and learning yeah you know
yeah III don't know exactly how to like
kind of even describe it because it's
always the way my life has been kind of
thing I'll get in the same way that like
a lot of kids like you know they go out
and they you know catch bugs and place a
lot baseball or whatever like yeah just
like Alec that's the way it is like you
don't really realize how unique
the whole situation is until you have
perspective because you have nothing to
compare it to really other than I guess
TV shows and movies things like that so
I knew that my upbringing was unique you
know I knew oh it knew it was different
but at the same time it's kind of just
it's not until you get some perspective
some life experience until you really
realize that oh wait this was this was
particularly weird you know I think one
of the aspects is particularly worried
about it is a lot of kids that grow up
famous they grow up on the set
yeah and they grow up constantly around
people who treat them very differently
than everyone else it's not just that
you're famous is that you're famous and
you're also the complete center of
attention mm-hmm like you're the reason
why we're here we're here to do this
television show we're here do this movie
we're here to do this thing you're the
star mm-hmm and that I think for a kid
that's a very strange place to be yeah
and especially look I mean I like when I
was a kid like even before I started
working I always liked being like the
center of attention kind of thing that
was - you know I was just I was very
boisterous you know but uh but in
general like I never really liked being
fussed over when I didn't like you know
like yet the hair makeup costume people
like poking at you all the time and
things like they actually wasn't a huge
fan after a while of kind of like being
that at center of attention you know it
it does become a job after a while yeah
yeah like early on you kind of just do
what you do like that's like I was good
at it and boom liked it in the same way
like that you do look anything that
you're like you like it's where the
child labor laws don't apply to acting
you they do do that yeah I'm pretty
well-versed in child labor laws well
how's that worked then it goes from
state to state mmm they can work you
like let's say like in New York they can
work you ten hours yeah but it stop
right there they can work you well if
you can't get a job if they're eight
that's what you're that's what you're
kind of like that's what their limit is
and at the same time you have to get
three hours of schooling and plus an
hour of lunch so really you're only
you're available window is only six
hours or something like that a day and
then like that also in like in that six
hours they're always like setting up the
lights for the next shot and you know
the hurry-up-and-wait kind of part of
you know of things that's why I looked
the second home alone it took like
nearly five months to film because they
can only I mean virtually every scene
and they can only use me X amount of
hours a day
anything but that isn't that the only
job that you can work when you're eight
years old I don't know why you can't be
a carpenter I mean I guess you can do
modeling you know I mean but like some
kind of performing arts kind of thing
like there are dancers and so forth
mm-hmm
because I was a I was a ballet dancer
before I was an actor
really yeah yeah I did ballet for a
number of years I'm a classically
trained ballerina right here yeah that
ballerina if you're a man I call it I
say I'm a ballet dancer mm-hmm but there
is a weird ballarino like that some of
them use and I'm like I'm not okay I
call myself a ballerina
look I just like can't it's two bros
like it's from Welcome Back Kotter so I
did that for a number of years and
there's a bunch of kids like in you know
that do that and you get paid you do the
work Wow so you know there are other I
guess trades yeah it seems like it's
show business though yeah yeah that's
what I mean I think it's more than the
Performing Arts kind of thing like you
know you don't see a lot of kids working
the coal mines anymore like that kind of
thing yeah for good reason all right but
some people think that by six-year-olds
dying a black lung you know there's some
horrible pictures from like the early
1900s of people actually working in the
coal mine doing their little tiny kids
yep yep yeah I mean there are no Newsies
anymore you know look yeah did you have
any say in whether or not you worked
when you were young
not really no hmm look it was after a
while it became like I said a job and it
was I like I never chose the projects
yeah they were like my parents I can you
essentially like chose them for me so
yeah exactly you know yeah yeah they
called you know class and like I never
read any two scripts look I would I
would just read like the lines for like
the next day or whatever like I would
like get the gist of what the movie was
about but then I just kind of show up
and hit my marks find my light you know
you know and and recite my lines real
it's kind of just like again it's what
you do right like it's like in the same
way that like like
kids go to like school or something like
that like you know you you you follow to
a routine to a certain extent yeah well
that's the thing about the human mind
right so flexible mhm you could adopt
any sort of weird scenario especially
when you're a kid I mean okay you just
bounce look all the time it's adapt so
easy
exactly exactly and I always had like a
good memory and things like that like
you know I liked you know I was I was
big and charismatic and I like had a
good memory like so I could remember my
lines like that's pretty much what like
if you you know like not gonna give any
advice to any people about like yeah you
should put your kid into this line of
work but at the same time like what
producers really care about is whether
or not you remember your lines but they
like people you never work with kids or
animals kind of thing yeah it's like
yeah and they want they they really all
they really care about is you remember
your lines really like because
apparently that's a problem like for me
never was look if I ever lost my place I
would just see the script in my head and
just read it look I think I kind of had
a photographic memory back then
oh it's faded now I'm 37 I'm about to be
38 in like two weeks
feels weird doesn't it yeah you know
yeah look uh my my bowels are different
[Laughter]